mary i can't do marriage with cody
anymore i don't want to
just look at the mountain i don't want
to do it anymore
sister wife stars cody and christine
have called it quits and on the family's
tlc reality show we're seeing how it all
unfolded you don't get to give up like
that almost three weeks after the couple
announced their separation after 25
years together the season 16 premiere of
sister wives revealed the rising tension
that eventually led to their split my
marriage to cody
is sad
the premiere mainly focused on
christine's desire to return to utah
while cody and his three other wives
mary robin and janelle want to stay in
arizona you guys are okay moving all the
time constantly i guess like i'm so
frustrated that we're constantly
bringing up where should we go i'm like
we gotta find a place and make it home
no no no i'm okay
i want you to understand i mean
christine brought this up the episode
also focused on the building and
development of their compound coyote
pass where the plan is to build separate
homes beside each other cody sectioned
off five parts of the property with one
space for his own home that would
include a pond something christine
wasn't too fond about
if you are all going to own your own
house why shouldn't i own my own house i
think it's stupid cody talking about
having his own house i guess he's gonna
use it for like family gatherings i'm
like what a waste of money there was
also this moment which didn't sit well
with christine
well yeah hey
what the holy hell did you just whistle
it up during the tour of the property
and once they made it to her designated
lot the mother of six expressed just how
dissatisfied she felt in her marriage to
cody honestly i'm i'm not excited to
move on to this property but we are
so i'd like to be excited to move on to
this property
i just have to talk myself into staying
constantly now instead of just walking
away
on november 2nd christine and cody
announced their separation on social
media
well
this is just kind of the place that our
relationship is at christine shared this
message writing quote cody and i have
grown apart and i have made the
difficult decision to leave we will
continue to be a strong presence in each
other's lives as we parent our beautiful
children and support our wonderful
family at this time we ask for your
grace and kindness as we navigate
through this stage within our family
cody who considers himself to be
spiritually married to his four wives
and is only legally married to robin
shared this statement quote christine's
decision to leave comes with a great
deal of sadness we enjoyed many years
together and i have a large amount of
respect and admiration for her although
we are moving forward on different paths
we will always remain committed parents
more than anything i think that what we
do
impacts our kids whether we want us to
or not honestly i guess out of cody's 18
children christine is the mother of six
she entered the brown family's plural
marriage in 1994 as cody's third wife
christine's desire for independence has
caused major conflict between cody and
the other wives and has been a central
conflict on recent seasons of sister
wives
we
don't have to do anything together it's
something et spoke to the 49 year old
about earlier this year
i really like living separate i like my
own space i like my own autonomy i feel
like i like me better now as and i just
feel like i've been able to
really
like raise my kids how i want to i
really have more of an independence and
i really i just
think the autonomy is really really nice
and i feel like as a person
that i do better with a little bit more
distance i'm sure that he would love to
see
everybody more often but the quality is
really really really important and i
feel like we're getting a better
better conversations
closer conversations
than we used to